if all your friends jumped off the edge
of a cliff would you do it too in
today's video we'll find out all the hot
new game changing frameworks talk about
their ability to run on the edge using
serverless computing platforms like
cloudflare workers and vercell edge
functions and just a few days ago next
js released version 12.2 with the
ability to opt into the edge for
server-side rendering and api routes
sounds edgy but what does that even mean
is it some magic new way to make web
apps faster or just marketing nonsense
you can ignore coca-cola with a new
taste a new explosion of wonderfulness
in your mouth i did some actual
benchmarking between vircell edge
functions and firebase cloud functions
to find out which one is faster in the
real world and the results are
absolutely shocking but first what even
is edge computing well traditionally
when you deploy a web app you rent out a
computer that lives in a physical data
center somewhere around the world like
us east 2 africa south 1 or tatooine
west 4. because you're poor you can only
afford this one virtual machine so all
requests around the world go to that
same server the problem is that your
users are all around the world the speed
of light is fast but not instant so
being physically closer is faster in
theory web developers have known about
this problem for a long time and have
been using content delivery networks to
distribute duplicate or cache static
files like html css and jquery on
servers all around the world that means
if someone from sri lanka visits your
website they get an image hosted in
bangladesh as opposed to iowa on the
other side of the world that's awesome
for static files but it doesn't really
work when you have a dynamic server that
needs to execute some code when a
request comes in edge computing changes
that it's like a cdn for a full-blown
server that means when you hit deploy it
doesn't just go to a single data center
but is distributed all around the world
as a developer they work just like
serverless functions like aws lambda but
without cold starts and are executed
closer to your end users sounds awesome
but what's the catch well in order for
the system to scale there needs to be a
very minimal run time that means nodejs
and the million mpm packages you have
installed aren't going to work at least
not out of the box you'll have to bundle
them with webpack and the total size of
your bundled code can't exceed one
megabyte that requirement can disqualify
a lot of applications but the good news
is that many modern full stack
frameworks like sveltkit nux js and now
next js have implemented the ability to
render on the edge what's especially
cool about next js is that it gives you
the ability to opt into the edge on
specific api routes or pages all you
have to do is export a configuration
object from that route it's nice to have
that flexibility because what i'm about
to say next might shock you edge
computing is not always faster in fact
it can be significantly slower in
certain situations allow me to
demonstrate in this project i have a
next.js app along with a firebase cloud
functions backend i'll be comparing next
js api routes which get deployed at
serverless functions to firebase cloud
functions that run on http the main
difference is that firebase runs on the
google cloud platform infrastructure
while the next js code runs on vercell's
edge network in this first experiment i
have a function that simply returns a
json response with the text of hello
world one thing that's worth noting is
that you'll notice in the firebase
function we're using expressjs to handle
that but in the versail function we're
using web apis because our npm packages
and core node modules are not available
the next thing i did is deployed both
back ends to the cloud using firebase
deploy and vercell deploy respectively
from there i opened up insomnia to test
out both endpoints from my location in
the united states the firebase function
generally gives a response time of
around a hundred and fifty milliseconds
which is pretty fast however it is
subject to cold starts which means that
if it's not been used recently you can
expect response times that go beyond
three or four seconds which is not fast
and could be a deal breaker for certain
types of apps the cool thing about
versailles edge functions is that
there's no cold start and not only that
but i'm getting consistently higher
response times than i am on firebase the
problem though is that testing from my
own computer isn't a very good benchmark
what we need to do is test from servers
all around the world luckily there's a
free tool on the internet for debugging
cdn issues that's perfect for testing
stuff like this it makes requests from
different locations around the world and
measures the speed of the response time
what we're most interested in is the
time to first byte which is basically
the amount of time it takes for us to
get our data from the server after
running it on both back ends we can see
that firebase is very fast in the united
states it's a little bit slower in
europe and a lot slower in japan and
australia why is that well this cloud
function is hosted in google's us
central one which is in council bluffs
iowa dallas got the fastest response
time because it's only 500 miles away
new york was second which is a thousand
miles away and then san francisco is
third which is about 1500 miles away
bangalore was the slowest which is
interesting because technically it's
closer than sydney and i think the only
logical explanation is that the earth is
actually flat requiring longer
underwater cables to get there good luck
explaining that one globetards fatality
now if we look at the versailles edge
function results we get more
consistently fast response times around
the world like sydney was actually twice
as fast as dallas bangalore once again
has a high response time but that's
mostly due to a long dns lookup so the
edge is clearly faster overall but
here's where things get interesting what
if your edge function needs to query
data from a database or api imagine you
have an edge function in new zealand but
your database lives in new york city in
that case the edge function will need to
go all the way to new york city then all
the way back to new zealand the end
result is a much longer round trip you'd
actually be much better off with just a
single server close to your database in
new york city even if the request came
from new zealand to demonstrate this
i've created some data in google's
firestore database then i created a new
cell function that requests this data
from the firestore rest api using fetch
and returns it as the response in the
firebase function i'm doing basically
the same thing but instead using the
firebase admin sdk to make the request
now when data fetching is involved
firebase has a huge advantage because
the data lives in the same exact data
center as the cloud function council
bluffs iowa vercell's edge network is
built on top of aws so the closest it
can get is cleveland ohio when we run
the test again you can see that firebase
got a little bit slower with data
fetching but the trend is the same where
it's faster in the united states than it
is elsewhere in the world the crazy
thing though is that when we run this
test on vercell not only did it get
slower but it got to the point of being
unacceptably slow like sydney now has a
full 1 second response time which is
more than 10 times slower than it was
previously and about three times slower
than the firebase function somehow
bangalore got faster which means the
earth must not be flat after all and is
in fact donut shaped the bottom line is
that the edge is much slower when remote
data fetching is involved the only way
to avoid that is to also distribute your
database around the world there are
databases designed to do that like
cassandra or you might use a secondary
database as a cache like redis the cool
thing about nexjs is that its engineers
are well aware of this and that's why
they allow you to opt into edge
functions on specific routes it's not an
all or nothing decision which really
allows you to fine tune performance now
the other thing to keep in mind here is
that you can also cache responses from
functions that means if your database is
far away you can cache the initial
response so you don't have to make the
full round trip on all subsequent
requests let's go ahead and benchmark
that as well in the versail function i'm
going to use the most basic form of
caching by setting a cache control
header that has a max age of 300 seconds
or 5 minutes when a new request comes in
it will send a response like normal and
then cache it on the edge that cached
value will stay valid for 5 minutes
before a new response is generated
that's important because it means it
won't do that full round trip to the
database if a cached version is already
available now what might surprise you is
that firebase cloud functions can also
cache responses on the edge as well to
do that we have to route them through
firebase hosting which has a built-in
cdn powered by fastly that can be
accomplished by rewriting a route and
hosting to a cloud function then in the
function code i'm also setting a cache
control header just like i did in the
versail function and now we can run our
benchmark again what you'll notice is
that they're both extremely fast
delivering responses between 10 and 50
milliseconds at this point we're
basically just comparing the speed of
their cdns and based on my sample it
looks like firebase is more consistently
fast but at this point they're both so
fast that the end user would never
notice i think the only way to properly
describe it is blazingly fast the one
issue with firebase functions though is
that you still have the cold start
however it is possible to run them with
a minimum number of instances which
means you always have at least n number
of functions running therefore no cold
starts but each instance will cost you
about five dollars per month and that's
what it's like to live life on the edge
if you want to learn more about building
apps with next and firebase together
check out my full course on fireship io
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one